I'm Tom Stewart, Editor and Managing Director of the Harvard Business Review.
Our guest today is Michael Porter, Professor at Harvard University and Head of the Institute for Strategy and Competitiveness.
He is the author of the forthcoming HBR article "The Five Competitive Forces that Shape Strategy,"...
...a reaffirmation, update and extension of his groundbreaking 1979 article "How Competitive Forces Shape Strategy."
Mike, thanks for joining the program. To start, let's remind our viewers of what the five competitive forces are.
Well Tom, the basic idea that competitive forces starts with the notion that competition...
...is often look at too narrowly by managers and the five forces say that, yes, you're competing with your direct competitors...
...but you're also in a fight for profits with a broader, extended set of competitors,...
...customers who have bargaining powers, suppliers who can have bargaining power,...
...new entrants who might come in and kind of grab a piece of the action,...
...and substitute products or services that essentially place a constraint or a cap on your profitability and growth.
So, the five forces is kind of a holistic way of looking at any industry...
...and understanding the structural underlying drivers of profitability and competence.
So, I use this to think about my rival makes it difficult for me. The threat of substitutes means I can't overcharge,...
...the threat of new entrants means I can't overcharge.
Right.
And the same thing with the buyers and suppliers.
And there's underlying drivers of each of those forces that the model really sort of unveils and then you can actually apply this.
Every industry is different, every industry will have a different set of economic fundamentals...
...but five forces help you hone in on, first of all, what's really causing profitability in the industry.
What are the trends that most likely to be significant in changing the game in the industry?
You know, where are the constraints, which if you can relax, it might allow you to find a really strong competitive position?
So how would you apply this analysis to an industry? Airlines, for example.
Airlines is a great industry. You've seen in the article that there's a chart that compares profitability in industries...
...and airlines I think has been on the bottom of that list for decades.
It's among the least profitable industries known to man.
And the five forces really allows you very quickly to understand why. I mean let's just go around the chart,...
...the nature of rivalry is incredibly intense and it's almost exclusively on price.
It's been very hard to differentiate, to get the customer to wait...
...even an extra two or three minutes for another flight if they can get on the flight with a cheaper price.
So, there's been a very intense price competition, low barriers to entry,...
...a constant stream of new airlines coming in to the industry despite the fact that profitability is low, it's always puzzling.
Low barriers to entry because you can rent a plane, you don't have to buy them.
You can rent a plane, you can lease a gate, it's all generic technology.
You can start with one flight between two city pairs. There's no real need to have a whole network in the beginning.
And yet people keep coming in. I think it is just one of those "sexy" industries.
It's a great example of how sexiness or coolness or hotness or chicness has nothing to do with industry profitability.
The underlying structures is what drives profitability.
Yeah, the customer is very fickle and price-sensitive.
Suppliers of aircraft and aircraft engines and even aircraft gates at the airports now have a lot of clout.
They can bargain away most of their profits.